[Music]
in no more spanking news Oh spankings a
good thing sometimes submitted by what
liquor liquor an elementary school ends
traditional birthday spankings after
parents complain oh yeah what the [ __ ]
wait who's who spanking the kids
probably teaches I hope not I don't feel
I remember this like they would slap the
but my parents and my uncles and we'll
use it we're back in my day we used to
do a spank machine where everybody would
like stand with the legs spread open and
you would crawl through their legs and
every will spank you as you drop that
sounds fun it was fun
the little kids yeah all the kids in the
class thank machine that's cute
it was cute I'm traumatized over every
time someone goes like oh yeah so this
elementary school is in Texas and
they're saying that they've had these
birthday spankings be a tradition for
about eight years now but then there was
this one parent it's always one parent
but who's doing it though adults on kids
or kids on kids oh no some kids is a
little I can see what do you have yeah I
don't want an adult touching tigers but
so they're saying that the birthday
spankings of course are not actual
spankings that is just like you know a
little like love top or something no no
don't touch him
with a paddle or a hand I don't know hmm
but well they just like a swan on the
backside give my kids a every day
birthday spanking every day did you tell
her thank you I just like that I have to
tell him anything hey young after your
date today all the time I'm only here
today so yeah nasty
ya know and then uh other parents
they're just saying like well this isn't
fair a lot of our kids look forward to
the yearly cuz it's a tradition and so
it's not like a punishment thing no no
it's like a little fun things
what the [ __ ] the proper birthday can
we just have these parents like fight it
out that's what I want to see anytime
there's one parent that's like boo and
the other parent that's like just fight
it out what's the name of that movie
with Will Ferrell fighting parents
I want to hear [ __ ] four minutes of
five minutes of [ __ ] not with you so
this is this is what I proposed you know
there's always that one parent that guy
wants to know though okay okay so you
know there's that one parent right that
always [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah whatever that
one parent complains about and if they
implement it something new like all all
girls who apply have to be cheerleaders
all boys that apply to be football
players have to be quarterbacks or
whatever the [ __ ] right picture of that
[ __ ] put them on the wall with
their address and the phone number this
is the this is the person that started
that rule I like that me too are you
guys afraid that when you guys have kids
like kids yeah like you go to you go to
the parent-teacher converse that you
want to [ __ ] up this pace oh I know I'm
gonna want to I get I get scared cuz you
know like I have a mouth on me look the
teachers are for the other parents of
all parents like that the teachers I
could just talk to but there's always
some kind of [ __ ] punk-ass parents
gonna say something oh I'm very
sarcastic it's like I know what I mean I
grew up in a school system because of my
mom so the teachers are [ __ ] [ __ ]
the teacher's assistants are [ __ ]
[ __ ] the kids are [ __ ] and their
parents are [ __ ] like everyone's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah for sure you're
gonna run into it dan that's I never
even put myself in that situation but
now that I have have you had any guns I
was about to say like Isaac's in fourth
grade now and I don't think
have encountered let's say something
like this you have like this but there's
just like this oh it's Tiger your kid
why'd you give him such a weird [ __ ]
name I'm in encountered any uncouth
maybe you should send your kids to a
Christian school what's a Christian
school Maya my teachers would know we
went to the same school oh we did we did
I got kicked out I know naughty boy you
know what the reason was my hair cut
really yeah
did you have this my again Asian because
all you did he had the bangs that you'll
come all the way back yeah big boy sig
sig naughty boy something happened here
just a bad boy man like my teachers were
cool I never I was never worried about
like whenever there was like a
parent-teacher conference day my parents
never came to those things so they
thought I was a latchkey kid you are
allowed to be careful while finishing
yeah that's right well that's good there
are those working at the business so
they couldn't come so it was it was just
a how to do that and then yeah it is
what it is but IRA Rogers their other
self my mom was always asking for a
conference all the times you sending up
wrong [ __ ] he's trying to take time
off work yeah parents hated coming to
school dude they thought it was a
[ __ ] well when they had to come to
schools because I got like suspended or
I did something stupid yeah but so they
always kind of associated it with me
being doing something bad and I think
that's what happened but you know those
parent like get-togethers or whatever
were you at the school [ __ ] my parents
couldn't go to it is it always working
yeah I don't think my parents ever do
that either they would go to the school
musicals and [ __ ] cuz I was you know
they know but that's about it
my friends were required to go they
would have open house and then like
that's what it was called I teach yeah
my teacher is always going your mom's
coming right I'm like what do you mean I
thought this [ __ ] was like the parents
get come if they want to do with no but
your mom she's required it comes I need
to talk to her yeah yeah Bob what the
[ __ ] those want to talk some [ __ ] what
are you doing I don't know I just I was
like a very troublesome kid like I
remember back there are no scratching
cuz I when I think when when I'm in
class at the time like I was just
thinking about this story so when I was
in class at the time like you just think
it's normal like when you're in junior
high you think oh there's
space in the classroom you better
practice your breakdancing moves right
so you're the homie order backs bids run
windmill on this line but then now what
do you think back y'all you [ __ ]
idiot you probably distracted the class
but I was always on the floor like
spinning around your [ __ ] story that
you told me in the car you jackass
that's just so [ __ ] funny the [ __ ]
debate team thing
ah ha I think I told him before oh my
god you guys remember the when I was in
any when Father United Nations again and
high schoolers debate and every single
year when I [ __ ] up the next choice go
I'm gonna be better and I'm gonna be a
better student and I want to be better
right mmm and then my freshman year I go
into I which through high school and
suicide is a pretty damn good high
school and uh I found out later on that
only a select few high schools actually
have mu n which is Model United Nations
so in addition to debate you actually
debate the way that you weren't what so
you you represent a country and if they
have a policy that you're debating on
you don't debate your thoughts you
debate on your country's thoughts so for
example if it's about child labor and
you're a third-world Asian country
you're fighting for your like this is
giving our people are giving our people
income and stuff like that so you don't
put your own morals into it hmm and for
mine I thought it was this is a chance
for me to do stand-up comedy about how
little kids have the best fingers to
solve Victoria's Secret underwear and
I'm like all of you guys all you girls
in here I know you guys love Victoria
member the last time you put on those
silky panties I just see my teacher I
think her name was mrs. Leventhal she
was just like I was a freshman in high
school okay
so Delta does my version of I [ __ ] up
enough in eighth grade and seventh grade
let me I'm actually do some work I'm
gonna make sure the work is good so I'm
gonna make it fun and I got kicked out
so I was out there like in like get out
of my class right now and I'm going out
there and it's it's a big event because
knowing there's people from other
schools they didn't even check your work
there's well I don't think they thought
well be that school it they're probably
like academia is high they don't need to
do that for these three
somehow he creeped it got into the
system and she's just like who the [ __ ]
is this guy is well literally said child
labor is okay because they need tiny
little baby hands to make all the little
jewelry headaches so I went into the
court yeah I got a presentation yeah
other homies came out and they're like
dude those props they like feel better
you guys got kidney I kicked out of this
[ __ ] you're like a lawyer about to
present his [ __ ] fight life-saving
and [ __ ] see I was trying to have fun
I [ __ ] up in junior high she could've
thought I was turning a new leaf but she
ruined that again no matter what I did
in high school it was nowhere near as
bad as this guy dude I'm like a saint
next to you dude it's crazy to be at
such a weight I mean I'm still tripping
off you feeling like you got a
breakdance every time you see an empty
air view we got extreme ATD I just have
that 5th grade or like I just wake up
and have two turtles in my hand wake up
with hella crazy yeah I got too much
crazy yeah I mean you don't have like
small remnants of that now you don't
mean it's just small better pretty bad
well I don't wake up a [ __ ] turtle
yeah that sounds more like like the
first time I did Vegas but then I don't
even know where he got these rocks
you're like what do you find rocks in
Vegas and I just am just skipping rocks
on the [ __ ] Street I'm like what are
you doing what the [ __ ] did you get
those dude happy returns yeah
and he got him from the Bellagio pond I
was like looking for rocks on the floor
I was like what the [ __ ] you get those
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]